Learner B4: أشوفكم اليوم.
Learner B1: اللغة اليمين.
Learner B4: هل هو الشباب العبور الله يعادل شو رأيك.
Learner B1: من المنتج.
Learner B4: الله أكبر إسمه زينب إمم.
Learner B1: يعني داليا محمد دي مش تبعندي دي حد معانا.
Learner B3 (20107207): مش عارفة بصراحة
Learner B3 (20107207): هو حد بعتله تاسكت الاسبوع ده ولا
Learner B3 (20107207): مفروض تقلل من تراعينا إيش معانا يعني.
Learner B1: أنا مهندس بعض الدفتر حتى شايف عليه أصلا.
Learner B1: ابعتلو.
Learner B3 (20107207): فلما سألت قبل ما انت عايزه معانا فرد ده آخر أسبوع يعني.
Learner B1: إمم.
Mentor B: وزيكو شباب معلش. أنا آسف، على التأخير بس كان معلق معايا ومش عايز أدخلت حاتم يبعتلي لينك تاني عاملين
Mentor B: يا ليلا
Mentor B: طب وين يا شباب.
Learner B4: سمعك كويس الحمد الله ولا يهمك.
Learner B1: تمام الحمد لله.
Learner B4: برشلونة.
Mentor B: شباب.
Learner B3 (20107207): الحمد لله تمام.
Learner B4: الحمدلله.
Mentor B: اللي فاتت عملتوا أبرهولي كده
Mentor B: مين اللي عايز أعرف منكوا أقولكم بس الأجندة بتاعت اليدينغ مين اللي عايز اعرف منكوا عملتوا
Mentor B: الجديدة عايز يشوف اللي طلعتوها بنتكلم فيها.
Learner B4: أم.
Mentor B: و.
Learner B4: مرحبا بيك.
Mentor B: يعني لو عندكوا اي سؤال نجاوبوا
Mentor B: حضرتك بتقترح اي حاجة نحطها في.
Learner B4: عندي بس سؤال هل ده اللص اسبرانت هل في ولا إحنا كده تمام.
Mentor B: في تسقط.
Learner B3 (20107207): هو سألني المنتر هيقلنا.
Mentor B: أنا تقريبا لسه تنزلهم بس
Mentor B: أنا حأكد وانا معي خود وقتك
Mentor B: على البتاع ماشي خليني أبتدي بس كده الأول أهم حاجة أنا
Mentor B: بالنسبة لبيت سؤالي كندا في فيسب غالبا حتزيد أسبوع غالبا يعني.
Learner B4: هو المفترض كان.
Mentor B: كان المفروض إن إحنا في داخل سبرينت
Mentor B: بس غالبا حتزيد أسبوع إن شاء الله.
Mentor B: في حاجة ولا.
Learner B4: لا لا خالص. أنا بس عارفة إن الدنيا تبقى ماشية الزاي.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي تمام طب يلا بنا مين يحب يبتدي ونبص عملتوا
Mentor B: عايزين نشوف اللغو والدموز اللي عملتوه
Mentor B: أخطوانا يلا عادي.
Learner B1: أنا مجهز.
Mentor B: ماشي يالله إيش
Mentor B: مش سامعينك يا بتكلم.
Learner B4: أنا بحاول بس أفتح لبجل. أنا أنا بحاول أفتح لابول بس أعطني تردي.
Mentor B: ماشي أوكي مريم
Mentor B: أوكي.
Learner B3 (20107207): تمام.
Mentor B: يلا.
Learner B3 (20107207): ثانية وحدة بس.
Mentor B: إيش
Mentor B: اللي يجهز يرفع إيدو على طول عشان نختار زي كده زينب إحنا كنا قبل ما تدخلي تشوفي اللافبلوس اللي انتو عملتوها عشان الحاجات ديكو فيدباك عليها عشان مهمة أشوفكوا فكرتوا إزاي وطلعتوا سولوشن ازاي وصلتوا للسيوشن
Mentor B: نقطه تانية لو عندكوا اي اسئلة نجاوبها ونتكلم في الإسبنت الجديد بعد تذكرة الاسمنت الجديد.
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي أشير.
Mentor B: ماشي يا الله يا ما في.
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي
Learner B3 (20107207): هو أنا المرة دي بصراحة ركزت بس على فكرة أكتر يعني بدأت يعني كان كل تركيزي على معظم فيدباك كان عليه
Learner B3 (20107207): إن إحنا نخلي توب كده يكون في شرح
Learner B3 (20107207): انديتيلز على كلمنت بتاعة كل ده ويكون وال ديليفيري بتاعته كريتيريا.
Mentor B: ولا ده.
Learner B3 (20107207): ده بس هو مش على ليفبل. أنا كنت قربت لفيبل بس ده مش.
Mentor B: باهي.
Learner B3 (20107207): بيزيرو.
Mentor B: فيزيو. أوكي ماشي ما فيش مشكلة هو نفس الإمكانيات.
Learner B3 (20107207): يعني حتى يعني برمتها حتى لذيذ يعني.
Mentor B: أوكي بس دي مش حاجة لذيذة في المجمل بس كم يعني لما تشتغلي في اللايف هتلاقي حسي دي حاجة بتقي
Mentor B: بتبوظلك الدنيا.
Learner B3 (20107207): ما أنا يعني لو حاجات ما عجبتنيش بقى فعلا.
Mentor B: أوكي.
Learner B3 (20107207): ويك تو ويس ثري فوري
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي وبرضه يبقى في راود ماب لأن هو كثير أصلا من يوزرز ما كانوش عارفين إن هم داخلين على إيه أصلا هو تقريبا أنا حاولت أه بالنسبة ليوزر فيدباك أو كده حاولت أعمل.
Mentor B: دلوقتي إحنا معلش قاطعتك حاجة عشان كلنا نمشي عليها واحنا بنعمل بريزنتيشن دلوقتي إنت دلوقتي برودك مانك حلو
Mentor B: فأنت اللي بتشرحله دايما بيبقى ستيك هولدر هو مش عارف ال بوسيز اللي انت مشيت عليه فأنت محتاج تفهمه لأن هو إنت لو كلنا وأي حد في شركة بجنب صح فأنت اللي يميزك عن ليه ياخذ كلامك ده
Mentor B: ليشتري كلامك باختصار يعني عملت
Mentor B: طب إنت إيه اللي عملتو عشان تعرفون ده صح أو غلط فإنت وإنت بتشرح دايما أنا عارف إن إنتو عشان الحاجات دي قبل كده اللي هو البوبلوم وإحنا فاهمينو ومعرفش إيه بس لأ ده لا يغني عن إن إنت تبدأ اللي إنت كنت بتحلها إكتشفت أسبابها وبدأت و بيوتايز أي أسباب
Mentor B: اللي اعتمدت عليها إيه وتوصلت لهذا اللي بيقول 1 2 3 حلو مش مش جنب على طول فعشان
Mentor B: ده أساس أنا بقولك كنت لسه بقول حتى أنا عديت مواقف كتير إيه كنت عامل فيها شغل كويس بس أنا عشان عملت بيزنتيشن مش حلوة خلت الدنيا باك علي
Mentor B: فاهمين فأنتوا محتاجين إن إنتو تعملوا محتاجين إن إنتو خلاص تبدوا بوبلين اشرحوا كأنه سيو مش فاهم المشكلة أصلا. أنت كنت شغال على إيه تبدأ من الأول خالص تبدأ من فكرة ماشية مريم.
Learner B3 (20107207): أنا كنت عاملة عادي حسابي إن أنا أعمل بس ما عرفش ليه بحس في ال إن هو يبقى محتاجين نعمل بسرعة ونشوف بسرعة فحسيت لما نعمل على طول على ليفبل إن إحنا بس سريعا.
Mentor B: ما هو ممكن.
Learner B3 (20107207): أنا ممكن أروح على ده ممكن أروح.
Mentor B: إنت اللي تحبيه بس أنا قصدي أنت برضه حتكون مظلوم في الوقت انت مش واخد وقتك مع أي حد هو الوقت ده أي حد وإنتوا شغالين دلوقتي بيندفع عليه فلوس
Mentor B: فانت مش مش متاح في وقتك برضه فأنت محتاج توصل فكرتك في أقل وقت ممكن فاهمة قصدي فإنت ده اللي حتحاولي تعمليه يعني.
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي طيب سريعا ولا أقول فكرتي على.
Mentor B: مش لانس لو تحب في البداية يلا.
Learner B3 (20107207): طيب ثانية. واحدة
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي يبين كده.
Mentor B: و40.
Learner B3 (20107207): طيب أول حاجة بدأت مثلا فيها هي ال يوزر بينت بوينتس المرة دي أنا بنتها على
Learner B3 (20107207): وجمعت كل جروب يعني أنا كنت حابة بصراحة، إن أنا أقسم لوحدهم المشاكل الفيباك اللي فيها الحاجات ليها علاقة بال جروب فأنا ركزت ال تاسك دي ميلي على.
Mentor B: الأرض.
Learner B3 (20107207): عندنا ال يوزر بين مثلا أول حاجة فأنا جمعت ال فيدباك اللي معايا اللي ليه علاقة بس بالبويندي ومثلا حاجة ثانية. فجمعت برضه كل فيدباك دي
Learner B3 (20107207): بتاعهم طبعا ده يعني من التاسك اللي فات.
Learner B3 (20107207): دي أول حاجة معانا.
Mentor B: صحف.
Learner B3 (20107207): مثل بي دي ار دوكي.
Mentor B: دي وأنت بتشرحيها
Mentor B: معلش أنا هتبقى وإنتو عندي كومنس كتير بس أنا الكومنس دي يعني نيتها مش يعني انتو عاملين شغل جامد والله يعني أنا شايفه بنفسي بس هي مش نيتها التعليق على قد ما نيتها. إن أنا محتاج أشوف كذا بوينت محتاجة تزبطهم.
Mentor B: إنت يا مريم وإنت بتشرحي لأ محتاجة تتكلمي بأبجيكتيف شوية مش أنا عملت هنا 1 إثنين 3 لأ خليكي شوية إنبساتك إحنا إكتشفنا إن اليوزرز عندهم المشاكل الفلانية الواحد تنين تلاتة دولت
Mentor B: يعني اللي إنت عملتيه على قد
Mentor B: يشو أب المشاكل الموجودة عندنا بترو أوبل ستريوشن فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B3 (20107207): ، تمام أوكي.
Mentor B: كملي قاطعتك.
Learner B3 (20107207): لا لا أي وقت يعني تمام
Learner B3 (20107207): نشرح بقى أول حاجة بروبليم اللي إحنا شفناها ونحاول اللي هي أول حاجة إن إحنا بيقل مع الوقت
Learner B3 (20107207): ما يبقاش في زي الأول وإيه تشالينجز عامة اليوزرز بياخدوها
Learner B3 (20107207): أنا بتكلم دوكيمنت ده أو ده بركز فيه بس على ال بروديتايب ده مش عامة مش
Learner B3 (20107207): فالباكراوند بتاعنا نحنا بنقيم إن إحنا يبقى في التاسك بيبقى مورستروكتورد وإن إحنا يكون في موحدة، أسهل يبقى أسهل إن هو يسلم التاسك ويبقى بالنسبة له مش أوفر.
Mentor B: مش.
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي إحنا أو أي حد بحب يعمل.
Mentor B: دي مشكلة يعني مشكلة مانجمنت سيستم اللي هو في في أو هي مشكلة اللي انتو لسه بتسكابو فيها
Mentor B: لأنه قلتلك تكلموا مع يوسف عشان تعرفوا أكتر وتعملوا ماركت ويوسف
Mentor B: حلو هي دي المشكلة اللي انتوا بتسكبوا فيها فانتي انتي لقيتي إن المشكلة برضه في كانت ليها علاقة ولا لقتي البوينس اللي لقيتيها محددة من فيدباك حتى من قبل كده.
Learner B3 (20107207): هو أنا ده هو ده الجول. عامة أوكي أنا عارفة أنا قلت بس هو ده الجول عامة أنا أكتوالي ابتديت إن أنا أتكلم مع يوزر فعلا.
Learner B3 (20107207): فحساب خالد.
Mentor B: أوكي اللي هي إنجمنت إنجمنتيد.
Learner B3 (20107207): اللي هم بقابلوها وإيه أسباب يعني أنا مش حابة بصراحة يبقى الفيد باك بس كده من برا أو.
Mentor B: أيوة أيوة صح؟ صح؟ المرة.
Learner B3 (20107207): فأنا جنبيها بعمل.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي.
Learner B3 (20107207): أم.
Mentor B: ماشي طب كمل.
Learner B3 (20107207): عندنا اللي هو فرش كاديوات أو أي حد حابب يعمل كاريوشت عشان يبقى في في كاب اللي بتبقى موجودة في الماركد.
Mentor B: حلو أوي.
Learner B3 (20107207): وده برده بناء على الفيب.
Mentor B: ال ماشي.
Learner B3 (20107207): الإنسكوب عندنا إن إحنا نخلي نفس فكرة نحاول نصلحها اللي هي نحنا نخلي تبقى ون سويس بس تبقى ديتيلز ستروكتورد يبقى الفيد باك ريليفنت
Learner B3 (20107207): بصراحة دي أكومشن بس أنا يعني يعني أنا مش بنعملها بالطريقة التقليدية معينة مش من معينة عشان ما نعملش ليمثل.
Mentor B: أم.
Learner B3 (20107207): دي شوية فيها.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي إنت كده كده لو حاسة دواويله على ديتا يعني ضوايلو على داتا حتى لو موجودة في أي ديت.
Learner B3 (20107207): بالضبط هي دي حاجة برضه كنت عايزة أسأل فيها أكتر يعني هل إحنا ممكن يبقى في إن إحنا نقعد ولو مثلا
Learner B3 (20107207): ولا لأ دي حاجة أسألها لكم إنتوا أكتر.
Mentor B: لو إنت بتتكلمي على دي تاني حاجات أي حد يسأل في حاجة يسألوا هاجر أو أو حاتم هاجر يعني عامة من شللهم ويقولولهم شوفوا اللي انتو عايزين وهما هيبو فايدز دي.
Learner B3 (20107207): لا، لا مش قصدي كده أنا قصدي. هل مثلا حصل في ممكن يستفيدوا أكثر لو في كورسيس أو أي بجانب الأزايمنز يعني حسيت ده حيقلل هل دي حاجة ممكن سبينس تعملها يعني الموضوع؟ ده.
Mentor B: ما هو إحنا إحنا أصلا.
Learner B3 (20107207): ما أنا عارفة.
Mentor B: لا.
Learner B3 (20107207): لين كذبة.
Mentor B: يعني ما هو دي بقى على فيجن يعني هل الناس اللي جاية تاخد الانت ناس أودي متعلمة
Mentor B: ولا يعني ناس عندها معينة فهي فاهمة جدا، فأنت مش محتاج تشرحها من الأول ولا هي ناس إنت بتصوت معاهم من من الصفر فأنت كأنك بتدوسلهم الحاجة وبتخليهم يطبعوا عليها
Mentor B: فعلى حسب سيغمنت بتاعنا وصراحة إحنا إحنا كده عندك إجابة يعني
Mentor B: مرحب بها جدا بس إنت فاهمة ليه السجمنت هتسمع بشكل مختلف في أحطلهم لكن أنا لو بطوجد ناس ودي خدت الكورس يعني خليني أقول إنتي ليفيلد
Mentor B: ساعتها ساعتها أنا مش محتاج أحط لهم ماتيريال فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B3 (20107207): أنا بقول كده عشان أنا أول ما اشتركت أصلا في كنت فاكرة إن هو كويس ستايل عادي أصلا
Learner B3 (20107207): فلما دخلت على حسيت. إنه كويس حلو ما كنتش عارفة أصلا نظام إزاي فحسارة إن إحنا ما نعملش لينك بالذات إن هو يبقى أوكي يبقى في ناس ممكن تعمل بس يكون عندها مرجع لو تطلع تقول أنا استفدت كذا كذا منس بس.
Mentor B: كنت تشتغل عليها على فكرة يعني تشتغل عليها بوتو طيب بس وزي ما أقلك ما فيش حاجة تكذب ولا تصدق دوت، فأنت ممكن تشتغل عليها.
Learner B3 (20107207): خلاص لا ممكن فعلا أركز عليها.
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي دي كونسترينز طبعا كلها يعني
Learner B3 (20107207): أول حاجة بس دي أكتوال أنا سألت فيها يعني مثلا كنت بسأل هل في تشانس إن إحنا يكون عندنا جروب تشات لوحدنا بس من أو كده
Learner B3 (20107207): هو قال لي إن هو كان ألريدي فاتت بس آي جس إن هو دلوقتي في حاجة ليميتد أو كده فحتى لي علاقة أكتر لأن هو يبقى محتاج إشتراك أكثر أو كوست يعني لسه بفهم في الحتة دي أكتر.
Mentor B: أوكي.
Learner B3 (20107207): نحن عندنا
Learner B3 (20107207): كل المشاكل. بقى زي إنشورينغ إن كل أو كل يعني كل يوزر ليفيل يبقى في كلها ليها علاقة بالإي آي أو نموذج كونسترانت وال أكرسي
Learner B3 (20107207): بعد كده في أوبن أنديت كويستيانس إنه إحنا إزاي نخلي يوزر إكسبيرنس أوفير والمنغ إزاي إحنا نقدر يبقى في كومبليت وكلوتس أكتر أو إزاي فيدباك اللي هو فعلا فعلا يساعد اليوزرز.
Mentor B: حلو.
Learner B3 (20107207): أنا عاملاها على.
Mentor B: لا ما تمشيش فيهم يعني ما تمشيش فيهم أنا خلاص أنا فهمتو.
Learner B3 (20107207): حاجة أقولها دين أناسك اللي فات فيها يعني فدي الحاجة الوحيدة اللي.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي.
Learner B3 (20107207): وعملت برضه سريعا كده بس.
Mentor B: الله.
Learner B3 (20107207): لسه عايز أفهم أكثر في الأبيك. بصراحة بس أنا تمام مع.
Mentor B: بك.
Learner B3 (20107207): باسك الأبيك.
Mentor B: الإيباك هو عبارة عن مجموعة من تخدم هدف 1.
Learner B3 (20107207): ما دا حابة؟ إن أنا أستكشف فيه أكتر يعني.
Learner B3 (20107207): استوعبه أكثر يعني.
Mentor B: أوكي.
Learner B3 (20107207): بس دي برضه تيكنيكال انتدريشن سريان أوكي
Learner B3 (20107207): وكل حاجة بتساعد يوزر ازاي عايزة يعني أفهمها أكتر.
Mentor B: إنت دلوقتي بتمشي في في الهاو كثير الهاو ده يعني على يعني على حسب قدامك هيبقى مهتم بالهوا ولا لأ يعني الناس بيزنس ليفلين بالهاو خالص السي ليفل مش مهتمين بالهاو خالص هم نوتن تريستيد
Mentor B: فإنت هتعملها ازاي هتعمل إيه والامباكت بتاعه إيه
Mentor B: حتيجي بقى للناس المهتمة بالهاو الناس المهتمة بالهاو دي الناس بتاعت الإنجيليين، فإنت هتشرحي هاو شباب الكلام ده كله لينا بتوعك. وكده اتفقنا؟
Learner B3 (20107207): ، أوكي، تمام.
Mentor B: دش.
Learner B3 (20107207): خلاص فبس ده مبني أكثر على والود ما بحسها طب أرجع ثاني للبروت تايب ولا.
Mentor B: يلا يا أورينا بقى ما هو ده الأساس.
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي.
Mentor B: احنا حنحط بس احنا 6 بقينا 6 في الجوف ده فاحنا مشان نخلص بعد بكرا وبعد بكرا كده.
Learner B3 (20107207): طيب أنا عملت تبقى كلير كده وأنا حاسة ده بجد حيسهل كتير بدل ما هو
Learner B3 (20107207): عندنا تنينت حد فيو حد يبعت ويبقى في اللي حصل إن إحنا لو زودنا زي تاب كده أو حاجة بتقول كل وتبقى موحدة لكل ده حيوفر كتير جدا جدا.
Mentor B: ا.
Learner B3 (20107207): وتبقى دي تيلد قوي
Learner B3 (20107207): حاسة برضه إن إحنا ممكن نعمل في الأول يوزر يبقى شايف هو حيمشي فإيه أو ما يبقاش تايه اللي هو كله بيك هيبقى كل ديتيلز بتاعته
Mentor B: وعاود.
Learner B3 (20107207): لسه بقى عايزة أركز أكتر في بقية تشالينج يعني.
Mentor B: أنا عجبتني الفكرتين والفكرتين حلوين ويضيفوا حلو أوي فيدباك بقى فيدباك الوكورمنت إنت ممكن تعملي شكلها
Mentor B: مش شكلها قصدي كيو آي قصدي بتاعتها أفضل يعني ممكن تبدأي تسأل تطوري عليها أيام إحنا عايزينها بيج يعني إحنا فعلا ندي الناس تلخبطها. في
Mentor B: أنا محتاج بقى أبص لكل يوزر أنا عامة يا جماعة حكيلكم برضه حشرحلكوا حاجة
Mentor B: انت دلوقتي كبودك منجر لما تدخل في أي بودكت بتاعك الناس بتستخدم برودكت ومش الناس اللي بتدفع مش شرط يكونوا
Mentor B: يعني ومثال على كده ممكن الشركة تدفع الموظفين هم اللي يستخدموا كده الشركة الناس اللي هي دفعت مش هم اتكسروا بس الموظفين هما اليوزرز
Mentor B: طب ممكن عندك ثانية إن إنت عندك أدمن عندك ناس أوبراشنال تيم ذا دو يوزرز على فكرة دول لازم تكون مش بس الناس اللي هم سي اللي إحنا فاهمينهم بمصطلحنا لأ أنت لو عندك طلبات مثلا عندها عشان دوبل ماركت فأنت عندك الطيارين دولت
Mentor B: فأنت ديزاين لكل دول حط ده في دماغك ليه لأن أنا هشرح لكم مثال حي على
Mentor B: فشل سيجمنت من دول قد يؤدي إلى فشل سيجمنت جميع سيجمنت الأخرى في عامة يعني
Mentor B: في كتاب حلو كنت تطلقوا عليه اسم بيتكلم فيه عن إن إنتو وإنتو شغالين في دوبلسايد ماركت لازم تهتمواد سيجمنت هاوس سيجمنت صاحبك تجيبها زي دايفرز بالنسبة الطيارين بالنسبة للطلبات السوبر ماركت مثلا بالنسبة لأي حد مثلا بتاع سوبر أبر ولا حاجة
Mentor B: فإحنا بنتكلم في هذه سيجمنت أنا كنت شغال بس وكنا شغالين على دوبل سايد ماركت فكان يوزرز عندنا الناس في المعامل. إحنا كانت منقدم ديسكاونت ميديكال و بتاعتك حلو
Mentor B: فمنين بتوعنا الناس 1 والناس برضه في المعامل اللي بيجيلهم بتاعة المريض اللي بيحجز التحاليل والمواليد بتاع التحاليل حلو ده كده سيجمنت المصغرة
Mentor B: إحنا ما كانت عندنا مشكلة فإيه فإن كل ما يروح مريض
Mentor B: ييجي ياخد التحليل وهو حاجز على أبليكيشن
Mentor B: ما يعرفش ياخد التحليل بتاعه طب احنا لما بصينا أكتر ورحت تكلمت مع قالك طلعوا إن هم أول ما يعرفونا قالي بص إحنا إحنا كنا ديسكاونت كارد فأنا عندي مية ديسكاونت كارد آخر غيرك
Mentor B: حلو وأنا وكل 1 عملي سيستم وأنا مفروض أفتح ال سيستم بتاعه فبالتالي الراجل ده حيهتم بمين حيهتم بالناس
Mentor B: الأشهر يعني هو الناس الأشهر مثلا كده وإحنا بنبتدي فطبيعي إن هو إيه ما يكنش مهتم بينا فأنا قلتله طب إنت إيه الحاجة اللي بتبقى فاتحها يعني طول الوقت أو بتكون قاعد عليها لو جالك عليها نوتيفيكيشن إنت حتكون دائما شايفه
Mentor B: لقيتو ان هو بيبقى فاتح الإيميل فاتح الإيميل بتاع المعمل
Mentor B: فعملنا بسيط كده وبقينا أي حد يحجز عندنا نبعت إيميل لرجل دوت فإيه اللي حصل بقى قبل ما المريض يروح ياخد التحليل بتاعه مجرد ما حجز جيل في المعمل يميل ويقله إن فلان الفلاني حجز ده لعيوبه
Mentor B: أحسن بكتير بس كانت مكلفة بس ذي بايل إنفي بي يعني أنت بتحل المشكلة بأسرع وقت يعني
Mentor B: فبدأ هو بقى إيه يشوف ده جالي إيميل فبدأ يجهز أصلا للتحاليل قبل ما يجي فبقت إكسبنس سموز
Mentor B: طب إن إنت برضه الراجل مش عارف ياخد تحليله فأنت كان هيبقى اليوزرز عندك وإنت مش عارف تسيطر على دوت ومش عارف حتى تعمل فاليو بوزيشن صحيحة
Mentor B: فاهمين فده مثال إن إنت لازم تبص على سيغنس كلها طب أنا بقول ده يبين ليه بشرح القصة دي كلها ليه لأن إنت محتاجة برضه طب هو ليه التذكرة مش واضحة ده سؤال مهم
Mentor B: ممكن يكون هل هي بريزنتيشن بتاعها مش واضح ولا هل هو انتقال التذكرة مش واضح باطل يعني ممكن يكون اللي بيحط التاسكات بيحطهاش واضحة، ليه فأنت محتاجة ترجعه ترجعي للأدمن إنت ما تحطشات ليه ومحتاجة ترجعي وانتو المشكلة في إن التاسكات ما بتكونش واضحة
Mentor B: حلو فخذ الفلوس كامل بقى وأنا بشرح الكلام ده كله مش كلنا تمام.
Learner B3 (20107207): هو بصراحة أنا فعلا سألت عن الموضوع ده كانت الإجابة إن هو قال لي إن في الأول هو اللي كان بيعمل وبعد كده المانتوس بحطه يعني لسه برضه بفهم أكتر في.
Mentor B: بس إنت عملها حلو أوي معجب بيه جدا بس أنا بشرحه حتى لو إنت كنت عملت بوست تي عشان كلنا نستفاد من من السايكل كلها
Mentor B: فشكرا يا مريم جدا.
Learner B3 (20107207): شكرا.
Mentor B: ماشي شكرا الكومنت التاني على الكومنت التاني على على واليوإكس إن هو يبقى لذيذ
Mentor B: زي ما بنقول فانك كده جنزي وكده فاهمة. أنا جنسي زيكو وانتو مش جنسي انتو جين اللي بعد 1,000 تقريبا ولا بس المهم إن إنتو ديزاينوا لنفس ال سيجمنت بتعتك اللي هي بتحب التوحيد.
Mentor B: نعم.
Learner B3 (20107207): سوري قاطعتك. كنت بقول بس يبقى مور فان يعني.
Learner B3 (20107207): خلاص إن شاء الله.
Mentor B: مين بعد مريم
Mentor B: يرفع ايده الأخطار
Mentor B: عادل جاهز او ياسر.
Learner B1: تمام.
Mentor B: يلا بينا.
Learner B1: تمام في الأول حابب قولي المشكلة كان عندنا الشيخ سامي أحمد
Learner B1: بروتايز المشكلة إن كان في في إن في الباك كان بيزن متأخر
Learner B1: تمام و لما جينا دورنا عن المشكلة أكثر عرفنا إن المشكلة من يعني وقت المراجعة كانت بتاخد وقت كبير
Learner B1: ترتيب الكويري مثلا كان بيبقى حسب الوقت مش حسب الأولوية، فده هو كان بيأثر بشكل كبير
Learner B1: كان بأثر ازاي كان بيأثر على المغتربين يعني هم ممكن يقللوا حماسهم أو ما يكونش
Learner B1: فالحل اللي إحنا عملناه لقيت عملنا زي فكرة بروتو فاهم إمم
Learner B1: أول حاجة بتعرض التريك واسمه اسم الانترنت نفسه. المشكلة فين
Learner B1: وثاني حاجة هم عندهم استعداد وصلوا
Learner B1: سواء كان في كذا حاجة مثلا ممكن يبقى مثلا ممكن يكون لسه كيري بتلوج
Learner B1: وهنا بيبقى في 2 ممكن يرتبوا على حسب الجنيه يعني حسب إي آي شايف أهميتها قد وعلى حسب وقت الوصول.
Learner B1: نعم.
Mentor B: طيب دي بتحل مشكلة التأخر بتاع الفيد باك إزاي بقى.
Learner B1: تمام في الأول تأخر فيدباك كان بسبب بشكل كبير مرة وحدة تمام وبتترتب على حسب اللي هو الوقت.
Mentor B: حلو.
Learner B1: تمام. فمثلا، أنا لما أعملها على حسب الأولوية تمام.
Learner B1: إن إي آي هو جزء جزء من كلها يعني حيساعدني مثلا إن أنا هو هنا. جابلي الإيروفين
Learner B1: المشكلة فين في في يعني وبيقترح حلول بس في الآخر.
Learner B1: أنا لازم أزود حاجة كمنتور.
Mentor B: شو عامل حتة دي يعني.
Learner B1: يعني إن الأستاذ يعني المسؤول عن نفسه أو لا.
Mentor B: لا.
Learner B1: برضه هو لازم يشوف إن تبعته صح ولا غلط.
Mentor B: دا قصدك بوزيز من بحيث إنو إنتو دلوقت هيكلية الطسكة يعني
Mentor B: فهو بيحط التاسك فأنا شايف فيول أد من دلوقتي.
Learner B1: ده اللي الأجمل هيشوفه إن هو خلاص هو كده بعثت وبعد ما بعثت خلاص تصححت أو يصححها وبيقول المشكلة فيه مثلا ده هو شايف جاف في الحتة دي شايف جاف في الحتة دي دي محتاجة تتراجع أكتر
Learner B1: وشايف إن الباقي تمام هو ساعتها في اللحظة دي هو مستني إن هو حد يدخل بعد ما يكنش يكون
Learner B1: يراجع بقى الكلام دا.
Mentor B: هنا طب انت بتعمل دول مراجعة ده ليه.
Learner B1: عشان ما توصلش الفكرة غلط ويكون في بيك ما يوصلش بشكل غلط وبنفس الوقت يعني يفهم بسرعة.
Mentor B: ما بس هو انت دخولي مش هوصل في البيت بصراحة.
Learner B1: مش هيكون يعني برضه فكرة.
Mentor B: بالعكس هو إنت غالبا المنتوج هتلاقيهم مش فاضيين وعقبال عليهم حتلاقي الدنيا بتصعب أكتر.
Learner B1: ما هو الفكرة؟ ما بيوصل لما بيكون يا إما بيوصل بشكل صح كامل.
Mentor B: ماشي بس دي مشكلة الاكيوسي أنت مشكلة السرعة والأكيوسي.
Learner B1: اي معلش.
Mentor B: إيه دي مشكلة الاكيوسي.
Learner B1: أم.
Mentor B: يعني إحنا نحل مشكلة.
Learner B1: الاثنين يعني هو كان في ناس من دول فيدباك اللي جاء لنا
Learner B1: فكرة هي اللي تكون مسؤولة بشكل كامل ده مش قصد حاجة
Learner B1: وإيه أو ناس معجبة بالإيه بس لو حصل ميكس هيكون أحسن.
Mentor B: ماشي فأنت دلوقتي بتقول الفلوج يمشي كالآتي: إن 1 بدل ما سميت الطازق اللي هيحصل.
Learner B1: يحصل مثلا مقبولة فيوقع حيفتحها هيشوف مثلا إيه اللي بالأحمر ده معناه إن في جيب الحاجة دي مش كاملة
Learner B1: مثلا اللي بالأصفر ده معناها ان هي محتاجة تراجع تاني العينة خلاص هو بالنسبالو باصو تمام ما فيش مشكلة
Learner B1: فمحتاج بقى هنا دور الإيه خالص تمام والفيد باك أهو تمام.
Mentor B: فيدباك ده يطلع لمين.
Learner B1: لا الفيدك هيطلع لو موافق؟ عليه تمام لو مش موافق عليه هو يدور عليه بقى الحاجات.
Mentor B: ماشي حلو مش فهمتك.
Learner B1: ومثلا لو النسبة كانت عالية، فهو ممكن خلاص.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي حلو طيب انت بأول قبل ما اديك فيدباك على التذكرة انت عملت موقف البزنس في
Mentor B: في البزنس إيمريشن ولا لأ.
Learner B1: عملت من البنتون ثانية واحدة هو لحظة غرفة
Learner B1: تمام برضو عشان ما ألغش نفسي وأدور على أي فورم خلاص اللي أنا عايز أدور عليه. إن يكون فيها إي آي إي آي دا يكون مصحح تمام.
Mentor B: لأ البزنس مختلفة عن كده ال هي فكرة إن إنت تعيش ليرنينغ لنينغ سبينس تخليها سيمونتيد كأن الناس بتتعلمشها
Learner B1: نأمل.
Mentor B: ، انت لو انت كنت فاهمها كده غلط عادي مش مش مشكلة ممكن تكمل بس هي تاخد هذا الكونسبت كونسبت ماشي.
Learner B1: تمام.
Mentor B: ماشي.
Learner B1: ما.
Mentor B: أوكي يعني محتاج الناس طب ما هو إنت عندك يوزرز أولي موجودين والناس اللي بتاخد اللي احنا فيها دي ما هي عبوة إلا عن بيزنس صح ولا غلط فأنت محتاج تاخد فيدباك بتاعهم
Mentor B: طب ياخد الفيد باك بتاعهم ليه أنا عايز أبنيلهم سبيس عايز أبني أصلا لسه مش موجود التذكرات بتنزلكوا على و وكده وانت عديت بمشاكل و بلوكرز كتير وإنت بتتعلم
Mentor B: ل 6 بقى الحاجات ديزاين بقى يعني خلاص أنا بقتارحه 1 2 3 ليكو كلكم شباب يعني عشان لو حد فاهم فاهم المشكلة غلط يعني.
Learner B1: هو الفكرة يعني كان المفروض ده أخلي حد من الإنترنت، صح؟
Mentor B: بس أنت ده صغير يعني صح؟ صح عادل بس خليك لما تعمل ال الأكبر خلي حد يجاوبك.
Learner B1: هي دي الفكرة ولا ولا أنا فاهم غلط.
Mentor B: سباغيتي.
Learner B1: إن.
Mentor B: ولا
Learner B1: أيوة أيوة.
Mentor B: هو ان الجواب دوت ده بعدين في المرحلة الجاية، لكن الفائت لا مكانش في تجربة حاجة كده.
Learner B1: إمم تمام.
Mentor B: ولا على حد ما نتذكر مش فاكر في حد نزلكم كده.
Learner B1: لا.
Mentor B: ماشي
Mentor B: فأنت هتعمل عادل. أنا عايزك تركز في الحتة دي عادي عايزك دلوقتي تبص على كونسبت بتاع ال بيزنس
Mentor B: شوف انت لو حتعمل بوضك حتنقي المشاكل الحالية في البوذك و ازاي حتحلها
Mentor B: وتشوف الناس اللي عملت قبل كده ليرنينغ عملت
Learner B1: أم.
Mentor B: ماشي بدؤوا يعني حتى حاول إن هو يعني اللي جاي
Mentor B: و أشوف إنتو يعني تشوف إنتو عملتوا
Learner B1: وكيف شاء.
Mentor B: أيوه
Mentor B: مين بعد عادل ندى جاهزة
Mentor B: ماشي يا سوى؟ جاهز؟ شكرا يا سيدي.
Mentor B: نحن مش سامعينك يا زربتك
Mentor B: حدثنا عادي يا شباب قصدي سياسة.
Learner B1: هو بيقول.
Mentor B: شفت
Mentor B: حاضر مشي آسف طب ندى جاهزة ولا مش عارف البيزانة النهاردة
Mentor B: فرن
Mentor B: ون
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي طب لو ندى
Mentor B: بص علي عشان بس الائتمانج ال هون دخل تاني هون سمعنا.
Learner B5: كده الصوت تمام.
Learner B1: قولي حاجة.
Mentor B: حقولك أنا.
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B5: لا، لا، تمام.
Mentor B: مش لا عايز أشوف وبعدين نتكلم.
Learner B5: فمش عارف أعمل سير النهارده عشان يتوحش خالص فا.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي.
Learner B5: سريع قبل ما يفصل يعني.
Mentor B: طب إنت عملت حيقولولنا.
Learner B5: ماشي حاضر
Learner B5: هو أنا بحس إن المشكلة. الأساسية كانت تأخير المراجعات وضغط الشغل على المينترز وإن جزء كبير من الفيد باك كان بيكون جنارك أو غير مناسب يعني وده كان بيأثر على على المتدربين
Learner B5: وبعد ما. حددت المشكلة حولتها ل بروبليم ستاتمينت وحددت أهداف واضحة. زي تقرير الوقت. ال تايم تو فيرست فيدباك
Learner B5: وتقليل وقت المراجعة مع الحفاظ طبعا على وجود المتر في القرار النهائي
Learner B5: بعد كده فكرت في حل يراجع السبب الأساسي للمشكلة فإخترت ريفيو أسيستانت لأن هيعمل مراجعة أولية بسرعة كده لكن المنتور يفضل هو اللي يراجع ويعدل ويعتمد النتيجة النهائية.
Learner B5: ورايح السرعة مع الحفاظ على مدة التقييم. طبعا
Learner B5: بعد تحديد الحل بدأت أكتب اليوزر ستوريز بحيث توضح احتياجات المستخدم وبعدها. كتبت ال أكسبتانس كريتيريا
Learner B5: باستخدام الجبن والون والزن عشان تكون واضحة.
Mentor B: أنا.
Learner B5: وقبلة للإختيار.
Mentor B: ألو حقول حاجة هنا نقطة يمكن عادل عملوا نفس النقطة انتو شباب اتجهتوا ناحية الفانيو ليرنر
Mentor B: بس ده مش دايما هدفك
Mentor B: إنت عارفك إن إنت تعمل كده بس هدفك إن ال بتاعة الشركة بتاعتك، تقدر فأنت ما تطلبش مستحيلات منهم في أشياء يعني ما تعملش
Mentor B: تقلهم ده حل مثالي عشان تدي فالو لفئة عن فئة أخرى. طب ما هو يقولك أنا مش المنتوج ما عندهمش وقت فأنت هتخلي المنتوج طبعا هيومنزد فيدباك منتوز فيدباك
Mentor B: حتبقى أفضل بس هل أصلا يعني لو إنتو جيتوا سألتو السؤال ده هل هل بتاعت الشركة عدد المنتوز ووقتهم حيكفي
Mentor B: فقاعات زي كده ما ينفعش تتاخد
Mentor B: بدون إن إنت ترجع للمنتج نفسه وتتكلم وتروح تتكلم مع الناس. ال ، السي او وتتكلم مع الهتز يا جماعة انتوا قادرين تزمندو وكذا احنا ممكن نخلي يعني إنت ممكن تعمل كده بس إنت لازم مع في هذه البوينت
Mentor B: حلو فدي نقطة أساسية خلاص لو اتفقتوا إن إنتو هتعملوا وحتعملوا دوت بالشكل ال
Mentor B: بالشكل اللي انتو هتضخوا منتوج مقابل إن إنتو ماكسيم
Mentor B: بس هو سؤال هو أي شركة إنت لماكسيمايز ماكسيمايز ليرنينغ فالو بتاعت اللنينغ سبينس هل هو حيدفع أكثر ويكوفر
Mentor B: هي دي معادلة هي مش المعادلة وخلاص ما هو أي حد يقدر يعمل أحسن موبايل في العالم
Mentor B: بس هو لو عمل أحسن موبايل في العالم بتلتمية 1,000 جنيه مين هيشتريه صح
Mentor B: إلا لو أنا بعتمد مثلا فابل بعتمد أبيع قليل بس تسعيري عالي جدا، فخلاص أنا أدابت كوفر ده بطريقة معينة فاهمين، فهي مش
Mentor B: مش عارف دول
Mentor B: مش فاهم قوي هذا بس
Mentor B: أحاول أنت ممكن تبعتلي الوكود وأنا أبعتلك الفيد باك متوتريش نفسك عادي يعني أنا إبعتيلي الوكود بعد ميتينغ وأنا حبقى أوض عليكي وأبعتلك فيدباك وإنت عملتي
Mentor B: ماشي فأنا في سؤالي اللي أنا كنت في يعني في النقطة اللي كنت بقولها انت ما ينفعش تاخد قاعات زي كده بدون ما يكون في أونلايمنت بكون ما في حزبة بي ان ال
Mentor B: فاهم ده أنا لأزود الفاليو كذا فده معناه إن عدد حيزيد
Mentor B: مفيش حد عنك هيبتين اللي هي تدريب ماة وحدة فيبقى انت عايز هدفك تزود عدد لما تزود الفانيو هتزود هتزودهم النسبة بتاعت الزيادة دي
Mentor B: نسبة المصاريف اللي إنت حتستندها في إن البنتو زي ينفسوا أكتر من وقتهم
Mentor B: فاهمين وانا معايا ولا مش معاي عدل.
Learner B1: موجود الفكرة دي طبعا يعني ما كانش سهل إن أنا أسأل.
Mentor B: لا، أنا فاهم أنا فاهم.
Learner B1: ده طفح ويعني أشاركهم بالحل وده شايف مضبوط بس.
Mentor B: بس أنا النقطة اللي إنت أكثر من إنت تفكر بأنقل يعني إنت مش جاي تعمل أحسن حاجة لأي حد وخلاص لأ مش دي المعضلة.
Learner B1: إمم.
Mentor B: هي أنت جاي تعمل أحسن حق بالزبط أحسن حاجة تطلع منه فاليو للشركة منه فاليو لليوزر.
Learner B1: ممكن يكون أحسن حاجة مش مناسب ليه.
Mentor B: أحسن حاجة مش مناسبة للشركة بالظبط وممكن العكس فاهم قصدي فهي نقطة دي بالانس أهم حاجة عشان أنتو تتكلموا حتى لو فكرتوا نقطة البي ان ال دي أنا هي مش نقطة مفتوحة أنا مش مفتوحة لي وصوف الدنيا والآخرة
Mentor B: لا خالص. أنا ليميتد جدا
Mentor B: فعشان كده لازم أنا أقوم بفكر بطريقة طب الأكشن ده أنا أخدته كوست علي قد وحجيب ليفنيس قد ودي لما كل ما تكبر تفكيكها يبقى كده لأن هو انت بتتحسب بيه ان ال بتبتدي ليفنيس قد
Mentor B: قشطة ليش.
Learner B5: تمام.
Mentor B: هنا بتقولوا أصل إحنا نخلي وقت ويدي فيدباك تمام حلو السيوش فيدباك أحسن بس أنا دلوقتي حقولكواشن ده أنا إيه
Mentor B: واقف بالنسباليوشن ده كده معناه إن أنت معناه إن إنت حتزودلي عدد المنتوج وأنا عدد المنتوج مش قادرين ننفست فيهم أكتر عشان عدد الفلوس
Mentor B: خلاص وممكن تقولي حل لأ ما هو ده الحل المثالي إحنا نتغلي على اللونوف عشان ياخد كواليتي أعلى
Mentor B: فاهمين أصدي فممكن نفضل نلبس في نفس هاخدها إنتو لو عندكوا حناخدها
Mentor B: اكتبوها زي كده خلاص غليلي الاشتراك بتاع انتشن
Mentor B: بس أنا هديهم كواليتي أعلى. بس أنا حجي أقولك لما تقولي غليلي أنا بفكر معاكم في السيناريوهات أقولك بس إنت ما تغلي ده معناه إن سيجمنت أقل هي اللي قادرة تدفع
Mentor B: تغلي فالسجمنت ده تقل هل سيجمنت ده سيجمنت دي بتغطي
Mentor B: ممكن يبقى عندك إجابة وممكن ما يبقاش عندك إجابة فعنجاوب فاهم قصدي فهي دي طريقة تفكيرك.
Learner B1: أم.
Mentor B: صرت تمام هون.
Learner B5: تمام فهمت.
Mentor B: ماشي انتو انا دلوقتي ياسر. انت قادة التلفزيون دلوقتي ولا لأ.
Learner B6: طيب وصدقك يا تمام.
Mentor B: أوكي تمام.
Learner B6: موبايل عشان أعرف جزاك الله طيب
Learner B6: واضحه.
Mentor B: لحظة يا سي معلش
Mentor B: واضحة بس يبدأ تشرح للكاتب تدخل قدامه.
Learner B6: مظبوطة.
Mentor B: ماشي يا الله.
Learner B6: المشكلة عندي في حتة المشكلة عندي كان في جزئية يعني لما يكون في فيدباك. وهكذا
Learner B6: فالفيد يتأخر فبحس إن هو يعني أسف
Learner B6: تمام فكان يوزر كان بحسن إن الفيدباك بتوعه دلوقت كبير فبالتالي
Learner B6: ده ده في عنده أخطاء كثيرة وهكذا فبيكون الآن
Learner B6: فأنا حاولت إن أنا أعمل بيوضح
Learner B6: تمام الكريتيريا اللي طبعا محددها ولما يوضح مثلا أي تاسك معينة يشوف هل التاسكة دي يعني متعددة قبل كده ولا دي جديدة وطبعا الكريتيريا اللي هو محددها وهكذا
Learner B6: بعد بعدين بعد ما يخلص يقدر إن هو يشوف قديش بور دي ويحدد كل تاسكت معينة فيها هو واقع في أنهي نقطة
Learner B6: تمام ده كده البروبليم ستاتمينت دي الجولز اللي عندنا البزس كولس وهكذا
Learner B6: في عملت الجفن والون وفين واللي هي الجزء المشهور في الموضوع ده يعني خليها.
Mentor B: حلو.
Learner B6: أنا هنا عملت طبعا سبرينت بورت استخدمت جيرة طبعا حوضح كل دا
Learner B6: عملت سفن ستوريز يعني على جيرة ماشي
Learner B6: اللي أنا جزء تيكنيكال اللي أنا عملته
Learner B6: يعني طبعا استخدمت في زيرو وهنا إشتغلت عليه طبعا الفندق باك وهكذا ماشي ديفندس ماشي
Learner B6: طيب انا دلوقتي ال ال الجيرابورد أهو ده الباكلوك بتاعنا
Learner B6: دي السفن ستوريس كل ستوري فيها الليزر ستوري بتاعتها الو.
Mentor B: حلو.
Learner B6: البورد برضه موضع فيها والضن كل ده موجود عشان
Learner B6: يس
Learner B6: بس عشان مغطية عليها المهم.
Mentor B: بس.
Learner B6: بتاعته هتلاقي هنا كل 1 في بتاعته موظفي الإسم والإيميلز بتاعته وكل حاجة وال سكورينج بتاعه
Learner B6: وهل لا وطبعا الموضوع بتاعته كانت تتكلم عن والريف بتاعها
Learner B6: وهنا الأساس منقدر إن إحنا نقسمه للكاتبوريز معينة عشان يقدر يوضح الكاتيغوري اللي هو وقع فيها
Learner B6: وهنا المينتر فيدباك تمام
Learner B6: طبعا كل نقطة فيها عندك البيندينغ وعندك ال ال مثلا الأبروفلوجكتد وهكذا فبعد ما يخلص كل ده المتر يقدر إن هو
Learner B6: للإنترنت عشان هو يقدر إن هو يفر بتاعته وهكذا وطبعا يسرع من ال إم تي تي اللي هي فيدباك وهكذا.
Mentor B: مش فاهم الحتة دي يعني مين اللي يعني هي دي آي فيدباك دي صح؟ أوكي ماشي حلو
Mentor B: طب كده انت كده في جواز السيليشيوشن خليت الدنيا مترتبة ليه هو قادر يشوف
Mentor B: وكده وديته وقسمت في الصفحة دي بقت في ديزلت فيدباك هل ده في سمعة الفيد باك حاجة ولا دي مشكلة مكنتش تحلها اصلا.
Learner B6: يعني فرع فيدباك لحدة السرعة إن أنا طبعا ممكن أتكلم عن المتر العادي اللي هو عنده كل التذكرات دي وكل الشباب دول
Learner B6: فقاد إن هو يأسس كل جزء بسهولة فقاد إن هو يصل يعني يدي فيدباك بأسرع شكل ممكن بعد ما يخلص كل ده بيقدر إن هو يعني
Learner B6: طبعا بيكون بعد كده يعني ما اشتغلتش عليها بس مثلا لو الكس ده يوضحوا الداتا بتاعته كلها وإيه الحاجات اللي هو عملها يعني ويبعتهاله بس أنا لسا مش ردش على النقطة ديه.
Mentor B: ماشي أوكي حلو وحلو اليو قوي.
Learner B6: تسمع.
Mentor B: حاضر مش أوكي طب إنت الصفحة دي مش يعني يفكر كده واحنا ممكن نحط فيها تاني.
Learner B6: تمام وأنا كنت لسه برضه ألعب في الجزء اللي أنا أسند فيدباك بتاعة الانترنت في مثلا لينك يقدر إن هو يقس عليه يعني والجزء اللي أنا برضه عايز ألعب في الجزء والتين
Learner B6: بحيث ان هو الفيد بقى اليوزر برضو
Learner B6: أو الإنترنت يقدر إن هو يأسس ال تيم اللي عنده ويشوف يقدر إن هو إيه يشوف الحاجات اللي عملوها كويس والحاجات يعني يعني إيه ما كانتش كويسة يعني مثلا زي مثلا زميلتي مريم كانت جزء اللي هي عملت بريزنتيشن فدي كانت حياة كويسة،
Learner B6: فقدرت إن أنا ممكن أرفلكت ده بعد كده على الأساسمنت بعد كده بالنسبة لي
Learner B6: فيبقى وإحنا كلنا بنستفاد من خبرات بعض وبنستفاد من بتاعنا أو للتزكية.
Mentor B: أم بس إنت عندك مش.
Learner B6: مظبوط.
Mentor B: أوكي أوكي ماشي حلوة يا حلو وعايز شغل تاني كيو آي ويوزر إكسبيرينس
Mentor B: وعايز أكثر في مشاكل أخرى عشان تبدأ يبقى عندك فولسيوشن يعني ودي فيدباك كلكم أنا حقولكوا الأسبوع ده هتعملوا وبعد كده نبدأ في جزء الأسئلة
Mentor B: انا انت دلوقتي ركزتوا على مشكلة فيدباك تمام ومعظمكوا فكر في حلولها وحرسناها خلاص أنا عايز قوة تسكير أوسع وأكبر من كدا
Mentor B: دلوقتي كانت ممكن معاكي فيدباك من اللينرز إيه فيدباك بتاعتهم على في اللي كنت واخداه ده.
Learner B3 (20107207): هو معانا كلنا.
Mentor B: ماشي حلو ينفع الشباب تحللوه تحللوه وتبدأوا
Mentor B: تدرسوا الموقت في البزنس وتبدأوا تتكلموا مع اليوزرز إختاروا مشكلة والواحد يختار مشكلة منه تمام ويعمل ديزاين ديزاين ليها غير الفيد باك يعني خلاص خلاص بس المشكلة
Mentor B: يعني 1 بقى ويحل كل المشاكل ده هيبقى حبيبي هيبقى حبيبي وكفاءة فأنا عايزكوا تسكلوا تسكلوا أكبر دلوقتي بتشوف اللي
Mentor B: وإيه اللي جوا معاك عشان تقدر تحط في النصيف دايما على فكرة ال في تبص للناس عملت وبصاكل الليزر بتاعك وتجيب الحاجة اللي في النص ده حيخليك بقى إنت إيه
Mentor B: يعني تجيب الحاجة اللي تحل مشاكل بتاعك بس أنت خليني أقول إنت عنكود أو عندك بيزلاين اللي هو بتاع الكومباتوس فأنت قادر تسرق عليهم فاهمين
Mentor B: فين المكورة بتاعت يعملوا كده عادي فدي دي النقطة الأولانية اللي عايزكوا تشتغلوا عليها
Mentor B: بيزنس طيب ارفضوا ما لقيتوش ناس شغالين في البزنس سيموليشن أو بيعملوها
Mentor B: ابتكوا إنتو بقى إبتكوا بتتكوا أنا بقولكوا الإكسبينس يا جماعة أنا دلوقتي عايز أعمل ليرنينغ إكسبيرز محترمة للناس اللي بتاخد زيكو كده
Mentor B: انت اصلا انت اليوزا فسهل عليك ان انت تتكئ وتشوف ال أوبشن تفضلي عادي.
Learner B1: الفكرة إن البورد أو الصورة المتشيرة ما بينا دي مش عارفين مين قال ماشي هي فيها كل شكاوي وحاجة حلوة. بس أنا عايز أعرف الشخص اللي قال الشكوى دي قالها ليه
Learner B1: وعشان كده أنا طلبنا إن إحنا ننزل فورم بس
Learner B1: أنا دي مشكلتي أنا متفق مع إن الصورة حاجة كويسة أوي محترم عايز أسألك إنت لما كتبتها على أساس إيه ليه قلت ده.
Mentor B: طيب أدخل أدخل يعني بص أ ساعد أنت هنا.
Mentor B: مش يعني أدخل كلم حد إنتشرت دي هي مش من ال سيستم انت بتمشي عليه إنت بتديك فيدباك على كل المشاكل الموجودة في إنت كلم إثنين 3 وهما حتطلع المشاكل بتاعتهم موجودة ليست في هذه
Mentor B: البود أكيد يعني وصلتلو معلومات أدق وإبدأ أحلها عادي مش لازم خلاص إنت حاسس إن هي مش بترويك سيجمنت بتاعتك. اطلع بوا.
Learner B1: ما هو تمام أوضح فكرة اللي هو فكرتين مثلا حد كان مشكلته إنه هو الفيد مأثر عليه وخلاص حبسه بيقل مثلا إلي كده بكده فلان ممكن أخش أكلم 1 ثاني يقول لي لا الدنيا تماما مشكلة
Learner B1: حاجة.
Mentor B: مش هتسأله في مشكلتي فين باك إنت بتسأل إيه عاملة إيه معاك إزاي تشالينجز إنتوا إبحثوا
Mentor B: إبحثوا عن إزاي تكتب تعمل أسئلة يكتبوها كله يكتب عشان هي مش تنزلكم في البولت إزاي تكتب أسئلة وجميع القواعد بتاعتها
Mentor B: وراها الجاية هتشك يوم الخميس حتشك معاكوا اللي انتو كتبتوه واللي دخلتوا سألتوه عاليوز وإيه اللي طلعكو كافين بك فأنت اعملها إنت مش لازم تبقى سبسيفك كان نقطة معينة.
Learner B1: تمام.
Mentor B: وصلتلك.
Learner B1: ما وصف تمام.
Mentor B: ماشي حلو مريم بتقولي حاجة.
Learner B3 (20107207): معلش. كنت بقول أنت كنت قلت نعمل دلوقتي للأسبوع الجاي.
Mentor B: البوينت بتاعت إنتو دي الوقت حتعملوا زيوز أنا كنت طلبت كلكوا منكوا كلكوا ده
Mentor B: بتدخل تسأل أسئلة مش أي أسئلة مش هتقولو
Mentor B: مش هتسألوا أسئلة بايز مش حتسألوا أسئلة مش أوبن إنتي كوتشينز يعني انت ليك روز دي كوتشنز إز أونو أو أو هتسألوا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم فانت في في بعض البونز
Mentor B: وإنت بتعمل يوزر إنت فيوز
Mentor B: لازم تكون فإبحث على إبحث عن إزاي تعمل يوزر إنت فيوز وابدأ وإبدأ بعدين فيدباك.
Learner B3 (20107207): أوكي تمام
Learner B3 (20107207): أنا عندي بس سؤال تاني معلش هو إحنا دلوقتي في الديمودي. هل كلنا هنركز على كل الفيد باك ولا كل 1 حيمسك بارت يتكلم فيه.
Mentor B: هنا إحنا بنقسم يعني إحنا هو بنقسم فعشان كده إنت كل 1 يمسكله اتنين عشوائيين كده نظموا ووزعوا نفسكو في الجوبات
Mentor B: و وأنا أخلي الناس تعمل الناس لازما برودكت تيم هيدخل معاكوا عشان يعملوا فالناس هتكون إنجست معاكوا إتفقوا على مواعيد و ادخلو كلموهم والأسئلة تكون جاهزة،
Mentor B: اتفقنا؟
Learner B3 (20107207): يعني كل 1 مش يعني أنا لما أجي في الداودي مش هقول لكل حاجة.
Mentor B: ممكن نمسك إحنا السمها إزاي إحنا بس منشتغل سبيس ونشوف البيزنتيشن ساعتها نعمل عادي مش مش هتبقى قضية بس دلوقتي اسباس باوت هتحلو.
Mentor B: ما هو بس إنت في 1 ممكن يمسك كلو اللي هو هيعمل كل ده ما عنديش مشكلة معاي اشرح السيوشن كله عادي
Mentor B: فاهمة قصدي بس إحنا ساعتها ما بينا عادي.
Learner B3 (20107207): يعني أنا مثلا ماسكة مركزة فيها أحاول برضه أشوف ثانية ولا الأحسن خليني بس.
Mentor B: خلاص إنت حددت لي مشكلتك بس اتكلمي مع مع اليوزرز بقى عشان تفلدتي المشكلة دي أكتر إنت ما تكلمتيش مع اليوزر فاهمة.
Learner B3 (20107207): على فكرة.
Mentor B: ليش عادل انت الامور واضحة بالنسبة لك عشان ما كانتش واضحه واضحة ولا إيه.
Learner B1: تمام.
Mentor B: حلو ماشي قلقان من الليزر ولا حاجة.
Learner B1: لا، لا، بالعكس أنا كنت عايز يبقى معايا الشخص اللي هو اللي معايا ده اللي بيعمل
Mentor B: أيوة إنت إنت شخص قوي فأعتقد النقطة دي حتحبها إن شاء الله.
Learner B1: تمام.
Mentor B: ماشي وهو عندك أي مشكلة.
Learner B5: لا، لا، تمام.
Mentor B: ماشي أوكي موفقين ان شاء الله قولوا لي بس لما أكون جاهزين عشان أخلي حد يعمل.
Learner B3 (20107207): معلش. أنا عندي آخر سؤال هو إحنا لما نعمل ندخل ونكلم هل يبقى الأحسن يبقى تشاتينج أو نبعتلهم فورم ما فيش يعني لو سألناهم إن إحنا نتواصل معاهم.
Mentor B: لا هو ميتينغ أصلا. ما ينفعش تتكلم مع يوزرز ولا تشاتينج ولا يعني قصدي ده مش حيبقى إيفيكتيف يعني.
Learner B3 (20107207): وأبعت لهم عادي برا.
Mentor B: أقول لهم إحنا عايزين كده أنا أخلي الشباب تساعدكوا في الحتة دي تعمل عنا الناس حتتواصل معاها عشان بس أتواصل معاكوا عشان ياخدوا منكم.
Learner B3 (20107207): روسي.
Mentor B: ندى عملت ده حلو أوي ندى شغل عالي جدا ينفع تتكلمي ولا لأ.
Learner B3 (20107207): أنا عملت مع ناس بس من يعني سبينس قديمة لأن أنا كنت حابة أعرف إيه الإختلاف المرة دي عن اللي فات برضه
Learner B3 (20107207): إمم.
Mentor B: بس هي في اختلاف الناس على ال مس وناس على.
Learner B3 (20107207): مع.
Mentor B: أوف.
Learner B3 (20107207): اللي أنا عايزة أعمله أشوف في التطور بيبقى فين ولو في مثلا اللي فات فين فدي حاجة بلوس أنا عايزة أعملها يعني برضه.
Mentor B: أوكي حلو أوي أنا مبسوط مبسوط عملتي برافو عليكي بجد
Mentor B: ما كنتش عارف انك عملت في اللي فات بس حلو إنك عملتي ندى كيف بتقول
Mentor B: كانوا 2 مش عارفة تتكلمي لسا بس ندى عادي يوم الخميس كده كده الشباب كلهم بتاعتهم في يوم الخميس ممكن تشرحيهن يعني ما تفتحيش حاجة
Mentor B: وبعتيلي كود عن الدم وكده طب ننتقل لمرحلة الأسئلة
Mentor B: الأسئلة اللي عندكوا يا شباب
Mentor B: عادي عندك أسئلة.
Learner B1: أنا كمان.
Mentor B: ماشي هون.
Learner B5: تمام برضه.
Mentor B: ماشي أوكي إحنا عددنا بدأنا أكتر من كده الناس المقطع من هنا في الطريق ليه
Mentor B: انتو رايحين تاكل وقت الغد ولا بس مرض الغدا يعني
Mentor B: موفقين عامة مش لازم يعني تستنوا ال ميتينج لو في أي سؤال لتوصله أنا موجود. تواصلوا إبعتيلي على سيفكر على طول
Mentor B: ماشي وبلغت الشباب الأخوة الأخوة السابقات
Mentor B: وإن شاء الله موفقين في اليوم النهاردة ما تكلمناش على وحاجات تعلمنا كتير كانت كلها فيدباك وكلها فيدباك هاوشيخ ما أنا عارف يوم مش حلو بس يعني في حاجة تبقى حلوة وفي حاجة تبقى وحش على طول طيب فعادي يعني
Mentor B: يلا موفقين ان شاء الله غول ويك يلا باي باي.